Salut, aujourd'hui on est lundi c'est le jour du vlog
Ce vlog là je l'ai fait pour la dernière de mon plateau
"Les Hallucinations Collectives et autres illusions fantastiques"
J'ai laissé la caméra à tous les artistes qui étaient là
et je leur ai dit "pendant toute la durée du plateau"
"la caméra est à vous, vous faites ce que voulez, je monterai le vlog avec"
Je vais passer au montage et je vais découvrir ça
Je pense qu'on peut rigoler
- Bonjour on voudrait des billets
- C'est quoi ça ? C'est une caméra ?
Le magnifique Photocall où nous prenons les photos avec les artistes
depuis...depuis...Quand est-ce qu'on a commencé le plateau ?
On a commencé le plateau le 18 juillet 2015
Et ça c'est Rabab
Rabab c'est un éléphant rose
Il se prend au sérieux mais ça veut dire Babar à l'envers
Mais qui est donc sur son canapé ?
Monsieur Philippe ROCHE !
J'avais préparé le catering
Qu'est-ce qu'un catering ? C'est le manger des artistes, c'est la nourriture des artistes
On dit que les artistes se nourrissent des applaudissement du public
Je peux te dire qu'ils se nourrissent surtout de Pringles et d'Orangina
(j'ai jamais vu Fabien Olicard)
ça c'est les ordres de passage
Y en a un pour Céline aussi au cas où
Ça c'est les pseudo-conduites comme je fais d'habitude
Comme ça si tu veux écrire
c'est tellemint préparé C'est grandemint brin bien (accent québécois)
- Mais ce ne serait pas une metteuse en scène ?!
- Ah dis-donc c'est moi ?
Attend je me suis pas recoiffée
Attend, c'est pas parce que je suis dans l'ombre là que...
On communique ensemble par télépathie, uniquement
Tout passe par la trompe
et après ça se transforme en ondes cérébrales
qui parcourent le long de mon bras pour arriver dans ma tête
Donc là y aura des gens...
là y aura des gens...
là peut-être y aura pas des gens
là y aura des gens
Installation du catering acheté et mis en place par mes petits soins
Placement de produit, placement de produit, placement de produit, placement de produit
Placement de produit partout !
Et si che fous fesez foir l'ordre de passage (accent allemand)
Pourquoi je prends cet accent ridicule ?
En premier ce soir il y aura Djamel Kaibou,
après y aura, bah moi de retour,
Kamel le magicien,
Artus,
Philippe Roche,
et on terminera par Zapata :
le speedpainter qui vous avez vu également déjà dans des vidéos
[Philippe Roche chante]
(par contre je suis vraiment très très fort au niveau micro)
Ce soir je fais un truc bizarre
euh comment vous dire?
Cesoir, le vlog d'aujourd'hui
la suite de ce vlog, je ne vais pas la connaître
Je la connaîtrais au dérochage
parce que je vais confier cette caméra aux artistes
La tean Mentalo mon pote
Encore un grand merci, Fabien pour tout ce que tu fais
Je crois, on peut le dire, tu es le meilleur d'ente nous
Voilà !
Ca ça veut dire que ça marche plus, c'est nickel !
Pfoua ! La plaie ce Olicard là !
Ba ba ba ba ba ba
- Un escroc je vous dit, un escroc !
- En plus je suis sûr il les a acheté ses followers, là, sur Youtube
- Oui il les achète, oui !
Ouais, en Thaïlande
Ah il a un réseau, il a un réseau
Bon il te le dira pas !
Penses-tu !
Avec un peu de chance il nous a laissé des trucs à bouffer
- Attend, tu plaisante ? Y a trois chips !
- Ah bah attend, c'est du Olicard
Du U, ah bah oui
- Ulicard
- Ulicard. Joli !
On sait comment il sponsorise sa tournée !
- Il joue, il produit, et puis même ça, donc voilà, c'est...
- C'est ça ! Mais c'est propre aux Rochelais
Les gens de La Rochelle sont comme ça
- Je savais pas que c'était en Auvergne La Rochelle !
- Oui [rires] Toi aussi t'aurais dû aller à l'école
Bon là, c'est LE vlog de la vérité
Il est temps qu'on vous raconte, la vraie histoire, quoi !
- Voilà, tous ses trucs et astuces, bien sûr,
tous les noms qu'il découvre sur scène sont cachés un petit peu partout,
un petit peu dans la poche, un petit peu derrière
Tout part de là
Voilà
- Y a un résidu de la semaine dernière là
Y a encore un nom
Alors !!!
- Vous allez enfin savoir le secret de Fabien
- Bah voilà
Voilà, ce qu'il a dans le...
- La valoche !
- ...dans la valise
- Pinard vlog ouais ! On a bien compris
- Nan nan sinon y a rien, y a que ça comme matériel, voilà !
- Elle est vraiment géniale cette caméra
- (Ouais elle est bien ouais)
- Par contre c'est où qu'on...
J'ai toujours pas compris où est-ce qu'on...
- Qu'on...?
- Bah, comment on voit les têtes.
Ah !
- Il est là l'objectif !
- Voilà !
C'est... Eh, nickel ! Et bah non je suis à l'envers !
- Ohlala !
Oh les hommes se préparent !
- Ouais pour une fois !
-Ohlala ! Personne va se mette nu ?
- C'est trop tard !
- (putain)
- A deux secondes près
Faudra revenir plus tard
- Attention, les coulisses, vous allez voir !
Attention : Philippe Roche
Chanteur imitateur impressionnant
- "Chanteur imitateur impressionnant",
y a des impressionnistes et y a des impressionnants
Attention, vlog Lentilles !
- ha ha ha
Je vais faire une connerie
Tout le monde pense que c'est mes vrais yeux.
Bah non, c'est du verre !
- un postiche
- Le film d'horreur !
- Bah on accueille Artus, ce soir
Voilà, Artus qui a cru que c'était jour de pêche aujourd'hui,
avec son ciré, la boîte de thon, la petite mouche, tout est là ! C'est parfait !
- Les deux boîtes à 5€, si vous en prenez trois, elles passent à 3€ la boîte, du coup.
Et pour 8€ vous pouvez repartir avec trois boîtes.
[rires]
Et c'est du thon...voilà !
- Placement de produits où... ?
- A l'huile ultra vierge
*Djamel Kaibou sur scène*
- En danse on est là...
en musique on est là...
en dictature on est là...
en conduite...
*Interlude entre 2 imitations*
C'est compliqué quand tu es célibataire c'est...
Oui oui je suis célibataire ça se voit non?
C'est dur pour moi!
Et en fait du coup j'ai ma technique
Forcément, je fais Samy de Scooby-doo
Vous imaginez arriver comme ça?
*Voix de Samy* Euh bonjour excusez moi de vous dérangez serait il possible d'avoir un  *incompréhensible*
[applaudissements]
*Kamel le magicien sur scène*
*On est d'accord on est pas complices, on ne se connaît pas ?*
*Non ? Grâce à Dieu !*
[rires]
*Est-ce que pour la première fois, à voix haute, Benjamin, tu peux me dire le mot que TU as choisi ?*
- [du public] il est comme toi tu es mystérieuse
*"Mystérieuse"*
[rires]
[applaudissements]
Voilà, pendant que y en a qui bossent sur le plateau,
y en a qui tweetent, qui Facebook, qui Instagram...
*Tu sais que t'es un peu gros quand tu vois plus ton zizi*
[rires]
*Et tu c'est que t'es très gros, quand tu sais pas qui c'est qui te suce !*
*Alors j'en suis pas à ce stade là encore, j'en suis pas à cette étape là*
*Tu sais quand t'as besoin de faire : "Rappelle-moi ton prénom ?"*
*Là c'est vraiment qu'il y a un soucis !*
*Non je suis conscient d'avoir un gros ventre, j'ai surtout un gros cul, voilà. Faut appeler un chat un chat.*
[Du public] ha ha ha!!
*C'était le rire le plus méchant du monde*
*Non mais j'en suis conscient, voilà !*
Ça c'est le mec qui bute tous ceux qui rigolent pas.
Reynald, nettoyeur.
*This is the rhythm oh the night, a night...*
[du public] Oh yeah...
Y'as des séquelles par là les filles...
*C'est vraiment un honneur pour moi de les avoir !*
*C'est que des copains, ils sont pas obligés de venir*
*Ils viennent pour me faire plaisir, pour se faire plaisir, et surtout pour vous faire plaisir*
*mais moi je prends ça comme un cadeau personnel, je m'en fiche*
*Je me dis "tiens c'est super, c'est LE plateau que j'aimerais avoir"*
*Ils sont là avec moi*
*Et Reynald en fait parti. C'est pas quelqu'un à la base qui est dans les théâtres, il fait vraiment des*
*des performances*
*Un tonnerre d'applaudissement pour Reynald Zapata !*
[Applaudissement]
*J'explique au public que pour cette dernière on fait un petit peu différemment de d'habitude*
*Tu te souviens pour ta première ici*
*j'avais demandé un thème aux gens*
*on va faire un truc dans le genre*
*Ça fait rire que moi parce qu'il y a que moi qui sait la blague pour l'instant*
*Dis, tu veux bien m'éclairer la salle, François ?"
*La première fois qu'il est venu, il nous a fait Le Joker, de Batman, dans l'univers du cinéma*
*J'aimerais qu'on boucle la boucle et qu'on revienne un peu sur le cinéma *
Zapatta: *- Eh bah, non !*
[rires]
Fabien: *- Mais c'est moi qui ai le micro*
*- Mais c'est moi qui ai les pinceaux !*
Fabien: Hein?
Zapatta: Mais c'est moi qui ai les pinceaux
*Alors tu vas t'asseoir...*
*Ce soir le sujet, c'est TOI !*
*parce que je voudrais remercier Fabien*
[Applaudissement]
Je voulais remercier Fabien
*Pas que moi, je pense, tous les artistes qui sont derrière aussi, pour son accueil...*
*pour l'énergie qu'il met à organiser tout ça, donc...*
*Big Up, pour Fabien !*
[Applaudissement]
*Prestation commence*
*Merci à Reynald Zapata*
Un tonnerre d'applaudissement pour les régisseurs du Grand point virgule
eh bien évidemment: Rabab
Il se prend au sérieux mais ça veut dire Babar à l'envers
On se rencontrera dans quelques secondes à peine à l'extérieur et on reviendra encore plus fort au mois d'octobre
et on compte également sur vous.
Et cesoir encore une fois un tonnerre d'applaudissement svp
Pour Philippe Roche
Artus
Kamel le magicien
Djamel Kaibou
Zapatta
Prenez soin de vous, Merci beaucoup je vous aime fort Ciao
[Applaudissement]
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo !
Moi j'ai adoré découvrir les images des copains,
et puis, j'avais eu un super cadeau à la fin.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit...
*POUCE EN L'AIR*
Ce soir je fais un Skype avec l'un d'entre vous pour faire la vidéo de demain,
il vous reste encore exactement trois heures pour participer.
Vous allez voir ou sur Twitter ou sur Facebook,
vous cherchez, j'ai dû mettre le message vendredi.
Répondez-y comme ça je vous inclus dans le tirage au sort, toute à l'heure, je fais le tirage au sort à 20H.
Si ce n'est pas déjà fait n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir
parce que le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous demain, à 17H
CIAO !